WEAPONS HERE IN FLORIDA.
TUCKER?
>> Tucker: MATT, THANKS A
LOT.
SHERIFF SCOTT ISRAEL WOULD
NEVER BLAME HIS OWN REPEATED
FAILURES FOR THE SHOOTING AT
STONEMAN DOUGLAS HIGH
SCHOOL.
INSTEAD, HE NEEDED TO BLAME
AN ORGANIZATION THAT WAS NOT
INVOLVED.
DURING THE 2004 TOWN MEETING
HE PLAYED THE DEMAGOGUE
AGAINST NRA SPOKESPERSON
DANA LOESCH.
>> YOU JUST TOLD THIS GROUP
OF PEOPLE THAT YOU ARE
STANDING UP TO THEM.
YOU ARE NOT STANDING UP FOR
THEM UNTIL YOU SAY I WANT
LESS WEAPONS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Tucker: DANA LOESCH JOINS
US TONIGHT.
DANA, MY FIRST THOUGHT WAS
HE DIDN'T SOUND LIKE A
SHERIFF SOMEBODY RUNNING FOR
OFFICE.
POLITICIAN, A RED FACED BLOW
HARD A DEMAGOGUE.
DOESN'T SOUND LIKE SOMETHING
A LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL
WOULD SAY IN A TOWN HALL.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT.
>> I COMPLETELY AGREE,
TUCKER.
I'M SO GLAD YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT THIS.
ULTIMATELY THIS IS THE
FAILURE.
THIS IS WHERE THE FAILURE
TOOK PLACE.
IT WAS WITH THIS MAN AND HIS
LEADERSHIP AS BROWARD COUNTY
SHERIFF.
AND I WILL HAVE EVERYBODY
KNOW, TUCKER, AS WELL AS
BEFORE THE SHERIFF TOOK THAT
STAGE, HIM AND I SITTING UP
THERE FOR THIS TOWN HALL, HE
WAS ALLOWED TO GO OUT AND
GIVE A RALLY-STYLE SPEECH IN
SPECIAL INTEREST AND WAS
NAMING THE NRA AND REALLY
SETTING THE STAGE UP TO GO
AFTER 5 MILLION LAW ABIDING
INNOCENT AMERICANS WHO
DIDN'T GET ALL OF THE 45, I
THINK IS WHAT BUZZFEED
REPORTED TIPS THAT HIS
OFFICE RECEIVED.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE THE
MURDERER CALL HIS OFFICE
HIMSELF TELLING HIM THAT HE
THOUGHT HE WAS A THREAT.
AND THAT POLICE NEEDED TO DO
SOMETHING.
FAMILY MEMBERS WEREN'T
CALLING THE NRA REPORTING
THIS.
THEY WERE CALLING HIS
OFFICE.
AND SO HE HAS A LOT OF
EXPLAINING TO DO.
ONE MORE QUICK THING,
TUCKER.
I ASKED THE SHERIFF ON STAGE
WHETHER OR NOT HE COULD HAVE
ACTUALLY ARRESTED THIS
MURDERER BASED ON A FLORIDA
STATE STATUTE THAT TREATED
ANYONE SENDING ELECTRONIC OR
WRITTEN THREATS OF BODILY
INJURY LAUNDRY ROOM OR DEATH
TO OTHER INDIVIDUALS AS THIS
MURDERER DID WITH THIS
CLASSMATES WHETHER HE COULD
HAVE ARRESTED THAT
INDIVIDUAL, CHARGED WITH A
FELONY AND THE SHERIFF DID
INDICATE THAT HE COULD BUT
THEN HE GLOSSED RIGHT BY IT
AND WANTED TO REFOCUS AND
SHIFT RESPONSIBILITY AWAY
FROM HIS DERELICTION OF
DUTY.
I THINK HE OWES A LOT OF
INNOCENT AMERICANS AN
APOLOGY.
>> Tucker: ALSO REALLY
TROUBLING.
HE IS NOT A CONGRESSMAN FROM
CAMDEN.
HE HAS THE POWER TO PUT
PEOPLE IN JAIL.
IS HE A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIAL.
THIS BEHAVIOR SEEMS RECKLESS
AND DISHONEST AND WEIRD
COMPARING YOURSELF TO MLK
AND GANDHI.
IS THERE SOMETHING WRONG
WITH HIM?
YOU MENTIONED THAT GAME OF
THRONES QUOTE.
HE MENTIONED IT AGAIN.
HE WAS ATTACKING ALL THOSE
THAT YOU HAD ON.
THE LAWMAKER HAD YOU ON THE
STATE OF FLORIDA WHO WAS
CALLING FOR HIS RESIGNATION.
AND I AGREE WITH YOU.
I WISH THAT THIS WOULD HAVE
COME OUT ON THE STAGE.
I WISH THAT THIS TRUTH WOULD
HAVE BEEN KNOWN AT THAT
PARTICULAR TIME.
IT SEEMED AS IF HE WAS MORE
INTERESTED IN TURNING THIS
INTO A CAMPAIGN STOP.
I WILL SAY THAT THIS REALLY
EXPLAINS WHY THE CORAL
SPRINGS POLICE CHIEF CAME
OUT AGAINST THE BROWARD
COUNTY SHERIFF THE WAY THAT
THEY DID.
THEY SAID A STATEMENT WOULD
COME OUT CORAL SPRINGS
FIRST.
IN THEY SEEMED TO BE CALLING
THE BROWARD SHERIFF OUT ON
WHAT I CAN ONLY ASSUME TO BE
SHOW BOATING WHAT THEY WERE
SUGGESTING IN THEIR LETTER
THERE HAD TO BE A LOT OF
DRAMA BEHIND THE SCENES FOR
OTHER LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS WHO REALLY, I MEAN,
THESE ARE THE GUYS WHO I
MEAN, THEY SACRIFICED.
THEY RAN.
IN THEY HEARD THE SOUND OF
GUNFIRE AND SCREAMING,
TUCKER, AND THEY RAN IN AND
THEY DID WHAT THEY COULD TO
SAVE INNOCENCE.
THAT'S WHY WE LOVE OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE OF WHAT
THEY DO FOR US.
AND NOW IT'S NO WONDER THAT
THEY CAME OUT AGAINST THIS
BROWARD COUNTY SHERIFF.
>> Tucker: ALSO TRANSPARENT
THOUGH.
I'M NOT BLAMING THE SHOOTING
ON THE SHERIFF.
HE DIDN'T COMMIT THE
SHOOTING.
A SERIES OF MISSTEPS BY HIS
AGENCY ALLOWED IT TO HAPPEN.
IS HE CULPABLE IN SOME WAY.
HE IS DIVERTING ATTENTION TO
THE OTHERS.
IT'S THE MOST BASIC AND
RECOGNIZABLE KIND OF BUTT
COVERING.
WHY DOES THE PRESS NOT POINT
THAT OUT?
>> I WISH THEY WOULD.
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IS
STEM MICK FAILURE HERE.
TUCKER, HERE YOU HAD THE 45
REPORTS INTO THE SHERIFF'S
OFFICE.
YOU ALSO HAD TWO FBI
REPORTS.
EVEN BIGGER THAN THAT, WE
HAVE HAD DECADES OF THE
POLITICAL CLASS IGNORING THE
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS HERE IN
THE UNITED STATES.
AND POLITICIANS WHO HAVE
REFUSED TO REPORT DANGEROUS
PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
ADJUDICATED UNFIT, DANGEROUS
TO THEMSELVES OR OTHERS TO
THE KNICKS SYSTEM.
THIS IS WHY WE AT THE NRA
HAVE BEEN PUSHING FOR
TARGETED ACTION AND OFFERING
SOLUTIONS ON THIS.
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
DO SO.
>> Tucker: IF YOU RUN THE
CITY WITH TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE
LIVING ON THE SIDEWALK AND
LECTURING US ABOUT GUNS,